[Music]
well again the lakers haven't given up
a lot of points to stars recently
and then you saw zach levine light them
up then giannis and then jason tatum
and tonight it's their number one guy
jeremy grant uh-oh uh-oh
stuart and lebron
stewart is hot
and everybody's coming out now
now this is ridiculous
you got he must have caught an elbow or
something but oh yeah he's he's got a
lot of blood streaming from the side of
the eye
look here goes stuart
[Applause]
yeah i think he's a little upset
you've got coaches
you got security guys look at dwayne
casey's like just
calm
down
and there's cade cunningham also
it was along the free throw line on the
free throw
and he's still trying to get loose
he is knocking over
and he's out of the game without
question
i mean this is like he's running through
the line
that's nuts that's just crazy that's
just crazy that's crazy right now
[Applause]
[Music]
that was the start of a 15-minute delay
and counting
the trigger is for a
loose ball foul first we'll have a
hostile act after and an altercation
that not easily dissolved
i mean there's nothing we can add
everyone can see exactly what we saw
well they've got i believe what they
announced was a loose ball foul on
stuart